- [Instructor] Katie
throws a ball in the air
for her dog to chase.
The function f models the
height of the ball, in meters,
as a function of time, in
seconds, after Katie threw it.
And we could see that right over here.
This is our function f.
So at time t equals zero,
the height looks like
it's a couple of meters.
And then as we go forward in time,
to a little under 2 1/2
seconds, the ball's going up.
And then after a little
under 2 1/2 seconds,
the ball starts going down.
And after, by the time you get
to five seconds or close to five seconds,
it looks like the ball is on the ground.
Its height is zero meters.
So then they ask us
which of these statements are true?
Choose all that apply.
So pause this video, and
see if you can work it out.
All right, now let's
look through the choices.
So the first one says Katie threw the ball
from a height of five meters.
So let's see if that bears fruit
or (chuckles) see if that's true.
So if she threw it from
a height of five meters,
that means that the y-intercept
would've been at five meters.
At time t equals zero,
we would've been at a
height of five meters.
Clearly, that is not the y-intercept.
It looks like she threw it from a height
of maybe 1 1/2 or two meters.
So I'm assuming that Katie
is not five meters tall.
So she wasn't on a ladder or anything.
She just threw it from her regular height.
And so we can rule out this first choice.
The second one says at its highest point,
the ball was about 31
meters above the ground.
Let's see if that is true.
So the highest point is right over here.
And yeah, that looks about 31 meters,
so I like that choice.
So I will select that one.
The ball was in the air
for about 2 1/2 seconds.
So we can clearly see
that that is not the case.
The ball was going up
for about 2 1/2 seconds,
but then it was going down
for roughly another 2 1/2 seconds.
And so it was actually in the
air for almost five seconds.
So I would rule this one out.
The ball reached its
highest point in the air
about 2 1/2 seconds after Katie threw it.
So let's see, after Katie,
2 1/2 seconds after Katie threw the ball,
it's right over there.
It looks like it reached its highest point
a little bit before that.
But they said about, so they're
speaking in rough terms.
So I think that statement can be true.
It's about 2 1/2 seconds.
If they said exactly 2 1/2 seconds,
I wouldn't have selected it
'cause it seems like it happened
at like 2.45 seconds
or something like that.
But there you go, those are
the ones that seem true.